so FoxNews and right-wing media are very
desperately putting together a concerted
effort to turn these wacky coronavirus
protestors into what is essentially a
new Tea Party and as you may be aware
there have been these mass gatherings
protests and states where people are
demanding everything be opened back up
regardless of safety regardless of
infection risk and Fox News has been
promoting them as if these are heroes
who are doing this rather than simply
people who are creating a public health
problem
here's judge Jeanine a Fox News host
praising one protester on her show
over the weekend Debbie Dingell who is
the senator didn't have nice things to
say about you guys and I was rather
shocked here she is a representative of
your state criticizing this this
peaceful protest and it was pre Tempe
SFIL saying it was inexcusable what
water Michigan's reaction to her well I
can tell you look at Michigan look the
nation what we've done with operation
gridlock and has ignited a fire that has
spread across this entire nation Arizona
Pennsylvania Texas I mean today New York
great example of gridlock people rising
up all across this nation all right and
you know a lot of people are very proud
of you Michonne and what you've done and
let me just say Debbie Dingell is a
congresswoman and not a senator of
course the issue isn't actually whether
the protests are peaceful it's whether
the protests are putting people at
health risk and of course they are and
as Caleb akarma wrote in Vanity Fair
this Monday the network and its most
important viewer Donald Trump are
amplifying the voices of a small but
vocal minority protesting state lockdown
orders they are turning these protesters
much like they did around the Tea Party
into a principled constitutional
conservative movement so remember that
with the Tea Party if you were following
politics at the time of the Tea Party
you had a movement that view very little
in terms of facts but that didn't stop
them from loudly and indignantly and
furiously in many cases asking for
policies that would be bad for them
personally but they were policies that
their side decided that they want lower
taxes for the rich is one that comes to
mind you have a very similar situation
here people who lack facts both about
the virus and about economics and about
just about everything but they are
advocating for reopening which would be
bad for them in the medium term because
the case spikes will occur and more
people will get sick and more people
will die and over the medium term it
will actually be worse for the economy
not better and you have Fox News and
right-wing media cheerleading them
Tucker Carlson hosted a protester as
well and thanked them for their service
in these protests Rush Limbaugh cheered
on the protesters by citing these
examples of American bravery and
sacrifice from the past that have
nothing to do with what these protesters
are doing Donald Trump of course tweeted
over the weekend liberate Minnesota
liberate Michigan liberate Virginia and
save your great Second Amendment it is
under siege Trump adviser Stephen Moore
who has been a vector of disinformation
lately Stephen Moore called these
protesters modern-day Rosa Parks which
really makes no sense and in fact
Washington Post columnist back max boot
with whom I don't agree that often says
that it's not Rosa Parks that they
should be likened to it's really typhoid
mary that would be a more apt comparison
typhoid mary Google her Google typhoid
mary if you're interested in this
typhoid mary was an Irish woman believed
to have infected 51 people with typhoid
fever believed to be the first person in
the United States identified as an
asymptomatic carrier of typhoid fever
that seems like a more apt
comparison then Rosa Parks to these
protesters and we have to work really
hard to prevent right-wing media from
turning these people into heroes or into
martyrs or into whatever they are the
problem not the solution and as usual in
Trump World in Fox World everything's
backwards notice by the way these
supposed small government constitutional
conservatives they're not protesting the
multi trillion-dollar bailout put
together by Trump which certainly
doesn't sound like small government not
a peep from them about it
there's nothing smart or patriotic about
the protests and yet you see them doing
that and not protesting trillions of
dollars in government spending it's a
spectacle and it's a pathetic one at
that but it's dangerous no matter what
we finally have a real enemy that we
should all be united against we could
all be united against and you have
people acting in ways that are
essentially supportive of the virus the
way they are behaving spreads the
disease it's a level of stupidity and
irresponsibility that should really
scare us but also the incoherence of the
ideology should scare us as well
government is bad so vote Trump because
he's an outsider but government is now
good so we should all support Trump and
everything he does even if he is taking
and exercising more power than we would
have ever said the office of the
presidency should have because Trump is
the best but now government's bad
because the governors are telling us to
stay home but wait a second government
is good because Trump is handing out
trillions and trillions of dollars that
in the past we would have said is a
complete overreach for government to be
involved in its incoherent they're wrong
ignorant dangerous whatever word you
want to apply to it the effect is more
people are going to die there's a
YouTube channel called up flip that
we're partnering with I would love for
you to check it out I've put the link
right underneath the video make sure to
subscribe to the channel when you're
there up flip is a channel that is all
about exploring small business and what
makes a small business successful
every episode interviews an entrepreneur
you take a tour of the business and
these are not generic interviews you
actually get a really fascinating deep
dive into the history of the business
the mistakes the entrepreneur made what
they learned what motivates them what a
day is like running their business and
you get all sorts of super interesting
and valuable insight about what it's
like to run that type of small business
as a business owner myself I find up
flips videos to be endlessly intriguing
even if you don't own your own business
it is really great for a general
audience it's stuff that I think just
about anybody would find fascinating and
you can check it out by going to david
pakman.com slash up flip the link is
right underneath this video when you're
there make sure to subscribe and click
the bell for notifications